the Joe Rogan experience so back to
these conversations yes you've had over
these 35 years the ones that you've
recorded what have you done with them
you just you're holding on to them I
just keep keep them it people get so mad
at me yeah because I tell everybody they
should do a podcast how mad do people
get at me okay I think you definitely
should well I should because I I like
doing this so much I just I really
probably like you I'm just super
interested in people yes I'm curious I'm
really curious part of the title of your
book yeah so in the kid that's oh that
was so curious mind mm-hmm I realized
that cheese I've done 35 years of these
at that time I might have been 30 and my
kids my four kids don't really know what
I'm doing you know like I'm really
spending a lot of time hustling to get
Edward Teller to meet me it took a year
and a half two years or Daryl gates it
was the craziest meeting of all time
Daryl gates the at least you Wow Wow how
was that the craziest okay I'll give it
to you very quick I'll give it to you
okay
so I really thought this guy he was you
know one he's one of the most well known
and most accomplished police chief's in
America I think there were three of them
and he was one of the three in a century
and and then Daryl gates I new created
was one of the creators the fundamental
curator of SWAT which was bringing
paramilitary tactics to the LA Police
Department he started out as a
bright-eyed strong-minded clean-cut guy
working for the police department and
because he was sharp he was the driver
to the police chief which was chief
Parker and then chief Parker the LA
there was a riot called the Watts riot
not the LA riots but the Watts riot and
the police went in and they were not
qualified to be in that situation and
they've kind of failed at that and they
felt they failed at it and Daryl gates
was liked by the chief's side the entire
time
and he kind of vowed to himself I'm not
gonna let that happen again
and when he had the opportunity because
he became later police chief and I'm not
not much later became police chief of
Los Angeles Police Department
he instituted SWAT and other you know
paramilitary tactics and a mind
discipline that was pretty you know it
was like creating you know like martial
law people would argue and and then we
went that kind of produced an
environment that I think many think in
my eyes I think myself helped an
environment that caused the LA riots
because there was a lot of inequity I
think human inequity felt I know I'm
getting this again a political and you
should tell me what your point of view
please on the LA riots yeah well I'm I
moved here after that okay I wasn't here
while that was going down right it was
pretty intense
yeah and the LA riots were a direct
response to the Rodney King trial yes
exactly and yeah that was a crazy time I
mean the reaction first of all the
reaction to the video the the video was
horrible watching Rodney King getting
beaten like that then you also heard
that they had been on the high speed
pursuit with him and that there was more
to that video like that was yes end of
their altercation apparently there's
much more physical altercation before
that video maybe if someone saw the full
thing they would understand well okay
you're dealing with a wild person who's
on PCP these cops are doing everything
they can to detain him yeah but there's
a distrust of the police in these
communities in the first place because
they had seen so much police brutality
right so that reaction that riot was not
just because of that one graduation yeah
it was an accumulation of different
events yes different interactions that
people have had with abuses of buildings
hot sure yeah
you know and then the whole rampart unit
and there was there was so much
corruption there's a lot of [ __ ] going
to yes during that time so all that just
oh yeah all that exploded exploded and
so that the thing about this story is
they're saying about I spent I I took I
got a me
would Daryl gates it was ten months on
the book ten months Wow
and ironically the day of my meeting
with him was the day of the LA riots so
I thought and it already happened 2,000
buildings on fire and everything and my
office gets a phone call from Daryl
gates office confirming my meeting with
him I'm thinking oh my god Parker center
is under siege you know it's like the
whole city is under siege he's still one
to keep the meeting at a meeting that
was on the books for ten months I
thought that's really crazy so I went
down I had a guy drive me and I went
down and they zigzag through like a
security clearance thing where Cano
other cars could get through that was
really bizarre you know like we see this
now often but they initiated this this
kind of maze that the car would go
through I get to the but I get to the
I'm get to the front door a couple of
police chiefs of police officers escort
me in they put me in a room they they
died Joe guys they didn't give me a
cavity search but just about everything
but you know it took my clothes off did
everything they really yeah I did they
think that you just a scrawny little guy
movies I don't know that you would go
rogue no no there's like that there's no
evidence over sure that's crazy so and
then I got upstairs
and he is sitting so calmly he'd already
ordered two tuna fish sandwiches
very you know utility you know very
utilitarian the sandwiches and we had
the potato chips and he said you want an
iced tea
I couldn't even swallow I couldn't eat
my food because it was so shocked by the
whole thing that he had so much he was
impervious to everything that was going
down and the City Council was on his TV
and on the TV out there and you know
guys police officers were running and go
chief you're on TV right now and they're
yelling and he goes he says to me and to
them ah this is nothing they'll never
give me out
he had so much hubris it was it was it
was amazing
and I thought well and he's so calm
about it and of course they did
they did get him out I think the next
day actually because the City Council
was really at very liberal guys on that
board people on that board rather and
it's it's a long insane story but I had
my meeting lunch meeting how long was
the meeting normal like an hour you know
it was a full hour so you just have
lunch and just pick his brain and yeah
just have lunch and ask questions you
know and try to act not be nervous or
upset about the and what's going on the
environment and the TV's flashing you
know like archival footage that they
shot days before you know or the day of
and buildings on fire and the Korean
Koreans shop Market somebody getting
killed and all that stuff they were
showing on television and he he was just
kind of matter-of-fact like this is just
what's going down as time it's just pass
wow I know it was crazy well it sounds
like someone designed for the job so I
couldn't record that one yeah obviously
[Applause]